[Applauso]
[Musica]
e oggi nuova sono in slide super evita
guardate un po cosa abbiamo
ma perché abbiamo queste lettere perché
il 30 stavo pensando khosla in challenge
potremmo fare questa sarebbe divertente
fare una slide challenge un memo e il
pensate manca me potremmo farla con i
fogli no con i fondi non si vede molto
bene potremmo farla con il tappetino
puzzle e infatti eccolo qua in pratica
dietro ogni lettera c'è un ingrediente
slime anzi no nun ce ne sono due
noi vogliamo prendere l'ingrediente
sliven dovremo trovare prima la prima
immagine dell'ingrediente slime è poi la
seconda immagine come il gioco memory
praticamente lo saremmo memory quindi e
alla fine come sempre chi farà l'hotel
più bello a vincerà e dovrete deciderlo
voi potranno quando il sondaggio è super
divertente non vediamo l'ora di giocare
e mi raccomando mettetevi comodi fa da
dire pop come lasciato un bel mi piace
questo video raggiunge il 30 mila mi
piace rifaremo lo slide muri però con i
numeri e non con le lettere quelli
spallino bene cosi poco
speriamo che inizia carta forbici un
sasso che porta fuori diverso carta
farmi deserto
[Applauso]
carta forme già fatto tutto io come tale
può allora che lettera figli allora io
comincio con l'avis di vitale mediano da
una tempera acrilica la merante marrone
speriamo che trovi anche lato così
costretto a metterlo dentro zaini
fu proprio allora che cosa vuol dire
quando becchiamo la franchezza devo dire
praticamente quella non è una vecchietta
quello il gelato al cioccolato
se becchi 2 cacchette l'altro bersaglio
decide cosa devi mettere nello slang ha
un'attenzione molto pericoloso per un
per fortuna per tua fortuna non è
beccato due cassette ma i mercantili
marrone e la bellezza quindi breve
ritiro
allora io scelgo con la s di storie
vediamo non esistono alterato per l'auto
nel modernissimo a prenderlo con idea di
dove possa rendere non penso che sia
nella mia vita
scelgo la hd hotel a pian piano che
scopriamo le caselle sti abbiamo una
buona memoria ci riporterebbero o no
dobbiamo cercare di nemo vent'anni
raccomando così poi noi siamo ritrovati
allora inizia con la erre di rosa
vediamo la devo stare attenta la r prima
dov'era l'altra cacchetta la m di napoli
[Musica]
sulla e di
la verde al 4
che cos'è questo camuffato sembra ora
conosciamo ora scelgo la non mi ricordo
se la uno che una scelta non mi sembra
di udine piccolo rabbia morrone io sto
benissimo dove il contante parlare alla
fine beccate primaverando voglio peccare
quindi non andrò a cercare l'altro ma
scelgo la
di ivo la mamma mia dove morì proprio
per caso allora io sono indeciso ora
voglio andare anche da questo lato la g
vigoroso questo mi dicono che fa ceo
certo si è allora una forma di testa
perché questa è una nuova edizione ma è
un certo livello almeno qualcosa per
niente grossi come si raggiunse
ovviamente meno messo nessuno slime o
penso allora che gli se non abbiamo
scelto un ora cerco la mia vita
vediamo lo shampoo micro camioncino sono
qualche pagina dove ricatto d'amore
qualche forti allora era da quelle parti
[Musica]
non mi ricordo sarà la io la l io lo so
come rowe provo con lei ma lei
[Musica]
dove il colorante rosa ma allora io
approfitto siccome mi ricordo benissimo
davvero lo shampoo nel sito lo shampoo
tappa poi grandi di salvare bene sotto
l'ala di anita c'è altro shampoo allora
puoi scegliere tu lo shampoo e reggio
come vedi news 500 quasi quasi scelgono
shampoo verde forse è meglio questo
credo che sta chapeau vert io almeno
qualcosa da quindi viva lista già dovuti
alla vita nessuno forse mi ricordo bene
colorante rosa forse non mi riconoscerà
nell'aereo nella s
per me forse era nella sd stories
citiamo dagli assessori che non è la
cuba
[Applauso]
anche se non ho la colla ma chi se ne
frega alberto al colorato ecco come
guardate quanto è bello per mettere
nella nostra città speriamo che prenderò
la palla altrimenti non ci sarà proprio
per niente
sembra un serpente perfette sembra una
lettera guarda sembra ma di e una e
forse mi fa dire che nella di e nella
iii troverò qualcosa
bene dopo si prova voglio scegliere una
lettera che non abbiamo ancora scelto
ma qui non abbiamo scelto la via twitter
[Applauso]
il pigmento il pm ipotizza lato quindi
c'è un'altra lettera che non abbiamo
scelto lavoro abbiamo scelta
magari non ti dico niente io trovo colla
o per te mi sembra che non dobbiamo
scelta attraverso tocca a me allora la
colonna sarà sicuramente qualcosa che
hai scelto tu potrebbe essere la b di
vitale
oppure la p ma non mi ricordo di una di
queste c'era la cacchetta proprio con la
p vediamo pd palermo ok uno sceglie un
altro pacchetto no ma come romeo in
imola
[Applauso]
secondo voi cosa devono scegliere
che cosa posso scegliere la vera libera
ma come è possibile che solo cose di
sfigata questo gioco cosa vuoi scegliere
per il mio strive vediamo io sono
indeciso tra una folla e uno shampoo il
tuo team e di colore giallo ok al mare
quindi vediamo che cosa fa se possiamo
scendere lo shampoo vera oppure possiamo
scegliere vediamo vediamo io ho scelto
presto guarda ti volevo dare il celeste
però il bagnoschiuma celeste però adesso
che ho visto questo ma adesso c'è un
visto che questo dove va bene lo metto
nello no no
che bel colore stupito che li metterà
caspita come questo mammamia indefinito
questo colore neanche la deliziosa del
benetton che click
scegli cercare di 30.000 di vediamo
molto bene quindi so dove siamo noi
dedicata o perfino c'è qualcuno che in
vantaggio sarà bellissimo robert e siamo
sicuri che oro questo mi sembra più
curcuma e ora sta bene il pigmento oro
nel verde secondo lui da verde dorato
basta non ne mettiamo proprio tanta
non si vede nemmeno l'oro ai sprecato un
ingrediente o guardo momenti che si vede
un pochettino disco vero che è precoce
nel mio sarebbe stato più bello siccome
ora devo nascondere sotto il verde
devo riuscire a beccare una colla
assolutamente non mi ricordasse lacca
l'abbiamo girata l'anci non abbiamo
girato a di sicuro le figura ci dica in
quella sarei ricordato
speriamo ora devo assolutamente
ricordarmi dove campo era l'altra è
ovviamente non me lo ricordo io ricordo
allora fammi pensare chiudevo ricordi
[Musica]
dove ormai ma perché allora dici e
sicura no no va bene proprio lavoro anzi
no proprio la nomina di test regola n
la o di otranto
oggi lo vediamo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
quindi l'abbiamo amore non è così
terribile come pensavo fortunato
preoccupare tra i più bello per ora io
sarò in vantaggio perché anche se tu hai
messo il detersivo perde scaduto penso
che ruota vincere non ti vediamo un po
non riuscirà dal pensarlo questo smile
per colpa del detersivo si è sciolto
devo assolutamente trovare bello il
colore mio dal regno
vorrei che se io metto al tracolla per
non farlo sciogliere trova in un
distruggerti no o no il detersivo la
soft devo assolutamente trovare al
tracollo magari della colla bianca sono
rimaste poche reti pessimi non è che non
abbiamo mai aperto ancora alla z
se vuoi guardare con quindi tanto ma la
young rider dove stavano in diretta ma
da te lo voglio girare quel punto spero
di trovarla con la bianca allora vediamo
una lettera che lo abbiamo girato ancora
forse è presto per dire se vediamo
famiglia delicati ricordo benissimo dove
sono basteranno nella enne di napoli
vediamo le mie palline hanno votato così
almeno diventerà franzi anche se c'è la
forza
spero di beccare la colla per sé un
brutto
ora sono rimaste pochissime l'essere da
erbe di milano
[Applauso]
benissimo
[Musica]
metterò tanto che siate se non fa anche
con un tarantino più chiaro cosa rimarrà
a me sembra che sono in glitter
sicuramente si può casa a caschetto
comincia a girarla mai qualcosa che
verde chiaro che finalmente lo slide
verde concentriamoci quali lettere non
abbiamo tirato ancora mi sembra la r di
roma vediamo
devo cercare di non beccare a
nessun'altra cacchetta il proprio nostro
cacchiata così scelto un altro
ingrediente l'ora la cra di hotel vicino
l'abbiamo ventilata diamo in vantaggio
perché stai anche così si sono in questi
due lettere quindi ma non mi ricordo di
avere una giara seguite però non mi
ricordo servono nell'aula è ovviamente
lo dico perché non me lo ricordo
allora cari segni mi facevo la pila
[Applauso]
dove sono i clip ecco che twitter stanno
bene con il verde nero o grigio grigio
forse saranno pure bene prendo questi
qua mi piacciono in zone come vuoi
speriamo un po di te li ha scelti io e
mischiamo non si vedono lati vario un
bel niente
certo che si vedono un allora una cosa è
certa non devo scegliere la r perché c'è
la cassetta questa volta me lo ricordo
quindi mi rimangono solo due lettere
l'audi udine e la v di verona
proviamo vediamo un po cosa mi aspetta
tanto tutto tutto
[Applauso]
non ci credo ho visto io accetto il
miele la dedizione del sociale
cercate la giacchetta a un peccato e
marrone roba e calzano beccato da una
colla il motivo è beccato pure quando il
colorante rosso
caspita che fortuna non è veramente
credo che io volevo una cosa per ultimo
non so se riuscirò ad attivare news live
termine un po metallizzato quindi forse
sicuramente è schiavo vediamo che colori
diventa non è male caccetta
non è vero molte parole molte volte vedi
ma se riesco anche ad attivarlo questo
lo sconto è caduto nella terra per
diventare così brutto essendo che è
rimasta solo la cagnetta la cacciata di
monelli non la voglio neanche io prendo
io
peccati peggiori dell'ultimo ha detto
che ora non ci resta che attivare il
nostro slime è vedere un po chi vince
dovrebbe contare poi pronti 32
ecco klein slime alla fine è uscita non
è marrone e franzo metallizzato vedete
che bronzo tra l'altro è successa una
cosa fantastica perché non hanno mai
messo le palline in uno slime
metallizzato comunque con dei coloranti
perlati metalizzati e ora le palline
sembrano delle perle guardate sono anche
loro parlate per le parlate
comunque ora vi faccio vedere come è
bello questo slime guardate chi colore
fantastico ottenne un po all'arancione
però mi piace davvero ti piaceva breve
perché siamo un po di sun eats mr
vediamo come se la cava
[Musica]
7 di sony che anzi me di amore per la di
vita e se mi batte benissimo ed è
bellissimo
guardatelo finalmente l'ho fatto io e
con fasi del lavoro dei glitter i the
colour coro league menti in realtà che
sono rimasti un pochettino coperti dal
verme per fortuna ricordate che bello
elastico
adesso si vedono meglio pigmenti ci
sentiamo un po di poking non succede
niente podio è il programma o poco del
si sente davvero molto poco
ogni tanto fa qualche bollicina dal 1 st
in semplice
era dai così quel colore vomitino lirica
del padre ride terzino bello guarda una
rosa ben jor chin e mi raccomando
lasciato un bel mi piace a 30 mila mi
piace la seconda parte con i doveri e
ora mi lasciava quattro cartellini e poi
cliccare cliccate su quella che
preferite e vorrei ritirarli